il m'a eu un truc de ouf
dégage dégage je t'ai dit dégage je te
fume regarde regarde je te filme vas-y
regarde le mec il était en train de me
suivre je ralentis je me retourne le mec
non mais je vais jalousie là dans cette
vidéo ce qu'on voit c'est que je suis en
train de rentrer du travail à 16h du
matin sans un coup dans ma fesse gauche
et en fait je suis en train de voir
qu'il y a un mec qui est juste en train
de se masturber derrière moi je te file
regarde vas-y cours en courant vas-y
cours je suis très jeune je vis toute
seule ça fait 6 mois que je vis plus
avec ma maman je suis esthéticienne en
alternance et bah pour arrondir les fins
de mois bah du coup j'ai décidé d'avoir
un deuxième travail c'est à dire être
marmais dans boîte de nuit donc ce jour
là c'était bah du coup samedi soir je
venais de finir ma nuit donc je rentre
dimanche matin à 7h du matin je rentre
dans la RAM de métro et je voyais déjà
un homme qui était déjà en train de me
fixer en fait mais je me dis c'est banal
parce que de toute façon nous les femmes
c'est banal qu'on nous fixe comme ça
dans la rue donc j'ai fait bon
je sors du métro et je me dirige vers
les portes et le mec se lève d'un coup
d'un coup il se lève mais comme si il
venait de se réveiller en fait comme si
il avait oublié que il devait descendre
là du coup moi je fais pas attention je
marche je me retourne pour voir si le
mec est là et je vois qu'il est là je me
dis bon il habite peut-être là enfin je
ne calcule pas j'avais dit je sentais
déjà ce petit truc je me suis dit là
c'est bizarre je me retourne une
deuxième fois je vois qu'il est de plus
en plus proche donc je marche de plus en
plus lentement et je fais mine de
chercher un truc dans mon sac
et dans ce temps je me retourne une
troisième fois et au même moment je sens
un coup dans ma fesse gauche et en fait
le mec il était en train de se masturber
juste derrière moi je le regarde
totalement choqué je lui dis tu fais
quoi là le mec était encore en train de
se masturber je lui parle il continue de
se masturber et du coup je l'ai tapé je
lui dis tu sais quoi j'appelle la police
j'appelle la police c'est bon j'appelle
la police je mets le haut-parleur il a
entendu le police nationale et c'est pas
en courant c'est barré j'ai raccroché
c'est pour ça que dans le début de la
vidéo je suis en pleurs parce que les
nerfs ont lâché et j'ai dit non mais
attendez mais là il vient de m'arriver
une dinguerie et je me retourne en fait
et c'est pour ça que je lui dis dégage
dégage je t'ai dit dégage parce que au
même moment quand je me suis retourné
quand moi j'avais le dos tourné lui
recourait dans ma direction
tout en continuant de se masturber
non c'était un parce que je pensais pas
qu'il allait revenir en fait moi je
voulais juste expliquer ce qui était en
train de se passer et c'était quelque
part un moyen de réconfort parce que je
savais qu'à 7h du matin j'avais des amis
qui dormaient pas je suis quelqu'un je
filme tout dans ma vie je filme tout et
quelque part c'est ce qui m'a sauvé
parce que je sais pas ce qui se serait
passé sinon si j'avais pas filmé si
j'avais pas sorti mon téléphone quand je
suis rentrée chez moi direct après mon
agression j'ai eu la police au téléphone
je voulais savoir ce que je pouvais
faire
et on m'a dit sans indiscrétion vous
étiez habillé comment et le pire c'est
que j'étais avec une femme au téléphone
c'était une femme et je lui ai dit mais
pardon mais je vois pas le rapport
et on m'a dit non mais non mais bon les
yeux tombés bon allez au commissariat
pour tes plantes c'est tout ce que je
peux vous conseiller et elle a raccroché
pourquoi tu as décidé de diffuser cette
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai
décidé de diffuser cette vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui se rendent pas
compte du quotidien que nous les femmes
on vit qu'on soit en jean en jogging en
jupe en short n'importe en tenue de
travail en uniforme mais n'importe c'est
insupportable je me suis dit bah en fait
faut que je parle pour nous toutes il
faut que tout le monde se rende compte
que surtout les hommes pour qu'ils se
rendent compte que tout ce qu'on vit
faut pas le prendre à la légère en fait
moi 5 minutes avant j'étais dans le
métro je voulais mon lit au final je me
retrouve à donner des coups de pied à un
mec qui est en train de se masturber
devant moi mais c'est loin d'être normal
encore une fois puis bah je ne suis
presque pas sorti
je sors je fais une crise d'angoisse en
fait je me sentais salie et tout à
l'heure quand je me suis maquillée je me
suis mise à pleurer parce que c'est
difficile de se faire belle bah alors
qu'on a été sali quelque part c'est
c'est trop pour moi
[Musique]